are you comfortable about his current
weight or are you concerned about it I'm
I'm concerned not so much about his way
but more about
um
his well-being
I don't know about you guys how many
people over the age of 60 do you know
that are 400 pounds listen giving humans
maximum freedoms sounds like a great
idea Until you realize that not all
choices are created equal one and two
not everything that you can engage in is
just born from free choice the addictive
properties of some of these things is
crazy recently
I lost a friend to cancer
timing figures today revealed that
obesity cost British taxpayers almost 14
billion pounds a year of these patients
cost of British Health Service twice as
much as those of a healthy weight but
the body positivity movement preaches
that fat is now fabulous and that is
craze is fat fluences who rake in cash
by posting about well being fat
that's what I hear today is a fetch
let's go I don't know how many times I
have to tell you because I'm gonna start
my morning off with a Starbucks iced
coffee
foreign
[Music]
people are watching apparently well Tick
Tock is like my next guest of putting
the pound in excess pounds
is just
89.99 do you like sweets well you can
get two kilos of sweets for 10 pounds
promoting obesity no I'm promoting a
good deal 25.99 for 63 rolls of toilet
paper a donut maker from tower all of
these products have two year warranty a
candy floss maker and a chocolate
fountain
okay so I'm joined by Tick Tock star
George keyman who you just saw there and
see it again before we even doing this
[__]
I think it was
it's got to be about
two and a half years ago so this is like
20 20.
like September October so this is like
pandemic
about like nine eight months in full
lockdowns
we inside we have to be we don't have a
choice they put in curfews they put in a
bunch of [__] they shut down every
social activity known to man this
[__] didn't leave his house for
like a month at one point that's me I'll
be honestly man that was probably my
most unhealthy
on active inactive
pitiful period of my life physically I
was at my worst you know since then I
probably dropped like 35 of course or 40
pounds
and I'm doing a lot better biking all
the time going out dancing all the time
and these are things that have like
revitalized me both physically and
mentally okay
when I see this kind of stuff I don't
you have every right to make whatever
choice you make when you go online you
promote these things
openly brazenly but I'm not promoting
this
all right this is going to be the one
time I'm doing this for a special
occasion but outside of that I would
never tell people to go smoke this on a
regular basis
when I tell you where you get good
Bargains or all this other stuff I'll
tell you to be very responsible I I
don't look at these people and get angry
I just get sad for them
these are individuals who are
eating at their lifespan because of
chemical chemically addictive products
that they choose absolutely but also
that we as a society encourage and
Market to them in some of the most
unethical ways are they complicit
absolutely but they're also victims
which is a weird thing to say you can be
a perpetrator and the victim of
something absolutely their bodies become
a [__] prison like it's not fun when
your knees hurt it's not fun when you
aren't taking [__] and you can barely
wipe it's not fun when you try to get
out of a car and you struggle none of
that [__] is fun now that [__] is
enjoyable and once you cross that point
of no return you're gonna wish you could
take back all them sweets that you ate I
don't know when I see this kind of stuff
I just I look at it from the side and I
think it's sad that we're going to lose
all these people who could otherwise be
productive who could be there for their
family members who could be leaders who
could be contributors who could be a lot
of things for their communities and we
lose them but even from the individual
perspective I think they also grow sad
knowing that they can't be there for the
people around them or for themselves
also
and I hope that you guys come back from
this I pray that you do but also we also
have to think is it okay for a society
that bans marijuana but allows these
kinds of products to be freely available
for everybody at any time that are
almost way more destructive and highly
addictive I think our society is
incredibly complicit in allowing for
these things to be propagated when they
prohibit other things that are less
worse or less bad than this I'm right
here smoking a cigar
is it healthy not if I do it every day
it's not healthy
it's not it's not it's not healthy I
know it's not healthy for example F1
the F1 is not able anymore because I
remember the days when cars were
promoted by tobacco companies do more
yay uh Marlboro they were on cars not
anymore we don't promote we don't do any
advertisement like that in magazines you
were you would look magazine and you
would you see cool packets of cigarettes
a Marlboro with a Marlboro cowboy and
all these you're not doing that you
don't promote it I eat sweets I do I eat
candy I do but I know I don't have to do
it all the time because it's going to be
very bad for me and this is coming out
from a [__] that has high blood
pressure and is at risk of diabetes yeah
so you tweets but I watch out for it and
I gotta provide for people around me
so even with this cigar in my hand
it's not something that I'm gonna do
every day so food companies used to pay
to be able to claim to our children and
even to our adults through advertising
that these things were good for you yeah
remember them back in the days back in
the days back in when you were watching
cartoons you used to come back home
after us a hard day at school and you
used to watch a bunch of uh cartoons
after these messages will be wide back
all right used to watch that and what
was there toys
and cereals and they were not new slicks
nope
it was all this it was Captain Crunch
Cocoa Puffs uh choco cooler whatever the
hell the name is the Fruit Loops Fruit
Loops
series
that's the French version because you
know I'm French
and they had to refrain from that
recently
I lost a friend to cancer very recently
because one of my girls
she left she gone
a baby girl love one year old
nothing we could do about that
it's over
and trust me
in those few weeks
that she knew it was about to happen
there was a lot of regrets
Insurance to talk to me about that [__]
there's a lot of regrets
and guess what
there was nothing I could do
and for someone like me that's someone
that cares for people and take care of
[__] like me was very hard
so you could promote all you want and I
understand the body positive movement
and at some point for that because I
understand why it's there
it's the extreme extremes that we have
to watch for saying that you gotta do
this every day
the rest of it I'm for body positivity
for real I am
we going on tour are we coming to cities
near you we want to see you
[__] face to face where you at
we gonna be doing shows all summer well
this summer we're doing three shows
we're doing Detroit Pittsburgh and
Washington DC but afterwards we were
going to England we're going to be going
all across America Asia so if you want
to get tickets make sure you guys go to
the website all right put your name so
we can email you as soon as those
tickets come out for your area we won't
bombard you with nothing else okay I
promise
um we want to see you guys at the shows
we meet us we have meet and greets we're
gonna have a lot of fun we're gonna do
laughing so it's gonna be a good time uh
but we want to see you guys first of all
right George let me guess some stats
yeah if you don't mind meowski how much
do you weigh look I'm not going to talk
about numbers because the thing is when
you well I think you should I mean the
thing is if I give you the number of how
much I weigh it's going to be all over
the sun all those trashy newspapers
tomorrow I don't need it don't need it
you're on you're on Tick Tock every day
showing us how big you are yeah and look
and you're proud of it no no no no no
that's the difference there's proud and
then there's just being positive in my
own skin and that's what I am right I'm
not I'm not proud
would you accept that by medical
definition you are morbidly obese look
if that's what medically you want to
call it then call it no you know your
weight I don't know but that's yeah you
could say that yeah right so here's my
issue with this body positivity thing
people shouldn't be celebrating being
morbidly obese in my estimation because
actually it is a dangerous condition
that causes many people to die look
you've got a fair point it is dangerous
it can lead to dangerous issues which
could you know diabetes and so on and
that is an issue but we don't encourage
gaining weight there's a difference
between the videos you just showed on
this channel
no no you're in you're showing people
encouraging eating food I'm just saying
wow look at the pizza look it's from
Costco it's no no no you're not you're
not sorry you are glorifying glorifying
stuffing
That's What It Is Well maybe that's what
it is
why is it funny because it is funny you
know but you should be taking yourself
seriously you know even for rappers who
glorify all this gun stock I think
there's terrible things it is it's not
good for our youth we see what happens
when these guys play with this stuff and
think it's cool the young people mimic
it
when you are somebody on these platforms
and you're promoting this stuff and
you're saying what a good bargain this
or that like you are promoting it maybe
you spend as much time talking about the
negative sides of yourself you know your
health and all that stuff but when
rappers get up here and talk about how
cool lean is I don't think that [__]
nice
and you got these youngins wanting to be
like them people who ingest this stuff
all the time and they want to have fun
you are promoting it you are doing
something that's bad but I would say in
all these conversations I think all the
emphasis is always placed on the
individual I also want to talk about how
we encourage Society systemically to
encourage people to make these choices
I don't think I don't think that the
government should step in for the same
reason I don't think the government
should step in a lot of stuff but
like drugs and stuff like that but if
you are stepping in drugs and you are
stepping in cigarettes and you are
stepping in tobacco and you are a step
in an alcohol and you're all stupid but
you're not stepping in sweets that's
where I think there's a little I
disagree on this point
you might be an individual but your
negative choices have an impact on all
of us there so when these people are
medically obese they put a huge strain
on the medical system they put a whole
huge trade on everybody else around the
fair drinking and driving that is your
individual choice you get on the road
you kill other people the government
steps in I think it's okay to say yeah
you are an individual you get to make
your own choices but your own choices
sometimes have an impact on the greater
whole and we have to look at that and
say is this good for society is it good
that we're fattening up our kids that we
set them up for failure for the rest of
their lives because we advertise these
things and we convince them that they
want it my knees don't even know about
refining sugars she'd been eating fruits
her whole life and she loves it she
loves it
she loves it but if you introduce this
[__] to them young you [__] with their
taste Pals to the point where they don't
even want fruits because they're highly
addicted already to sugars is it okay to
make kids suffer that because their
parents want to
I remember like you know we talking
about sugars and [__] like that that'd
be [__] kids up every single day
every day but if a parent was trying to
give their kids alcohol or weed or
whatever the [__] it is everybody all of
a sudden got an issue because they could
[__] with their development what do you
think sugar does it's funny about
yourself I actually don't find this
gonna sell funny I think come on I
actually think it's quite sad it's
comedy let me bring it well I know it is
I you know it is you know it is please
I've been an actor for 13 years no
George damn right now this industry come
on let me just go to Blair white in
Austin in Texas Blair I do have a
problem with this because I think it's
celebrating a dangerous health condition
and and if you're an influencer why
would you want to influence people to
think that that is a funny entertaining
and be something they want to do
well you should have an issue with it
you know my opinion is that the fat
positivity movement is a death cult you
know I'm all about living my life on my
own terms being happy finding a partner
that makes me happy but you know life is
short so you have to find happiness but
what cuts it in half is being obese your
life will literally end halfway of the
length that you would live being obese
and so promoting it you wouldn't be able
to be anorexic on Tick Tock and not get
comments about how you need to eat a
cheeseburger how you need to gain weight
and you can write it off as Trolls but
it's the truth you know I've seen some
tick tocks made by him where he is
addressing people telling him that he
needs to lose weight as trolls and sort
of making fun of it and I just wonder
you know is it really trolls I mean
certainly there are mean people on the
internet but there is some truth to it I
mean I know that he is a father and the
idea that you will in all likelihood in
all certainty actually not live past 50
60 years old is an issue so okay for me
you know okay yeah I know hey I'm not
that's that's my view I want to bring in
Sienna your wife you've been listening
to this yeah are you comfortable
completely when you see that the
statistics about obesity in this country
the cost to the NHS what it costs the
country yeah are you comfortable about
this
the way I see it is firstly just us
personally
um where we have Private health care so
that NHS isn't a thing for us I do
understand that it is costing the NHS a
lot I think it's a bigger problem to
address though I think it's about
educating people when they're young to
make healthy food choices I
[__] you're on tick tock who do
you think is educating young people
unfortunately with a relax or not social
media especially Tick Tock is geared
towards young people
well Tick-Tock is yeah you know you want
to say these are laughs or gimmicks when
you're getting sponsored by some of
these companies why do you think they're
sponsoring you because they think it's
funny
you think they're giving you money
because they think that shit's sweet no
it's my pun intended
they're giving you money because they
make money I know I work with
advertisers best believe they wouldn't
give me a [__] dime if it didn't mean
sales for themselves they give you that
money and they track that [__] because
they know it work there's a return on
investment so all these influencers who
are gaining traction gaining
endorsements the reason why is because
they have an influence on these people
that's why I don't advertise products
that I think would actually be bad for
my audience I only advertise stuff that
I actually like or believe it if I if
tobacco companies have come to me I've
said no there's a bunch of different
companies that have come to me I've said
no because I understand the things I
influence I know there's going to be
audience members who are going to buy
you gotta own that you can't sit there
and say no no these are jokes these are
jokes that's not the truth people are
buying stuff after you say [__] people
are taking interest in these sales
because you said [__] that's the truth I
think a lot of the time when you grow up
um in poverty uh like George and I have
um a lot of the time you don't have um
the healthiest options but my response
to that would be okay but you've managed
not to
end up as George has Weight Wise I don't
mean to denigrate you George so couldn't
that yeah
I think it's genetics no I I believe
it's because my parents were like cool
hippie vegetarians whereas um Georges
were not are you comfortable you got us
a son right are you comfortable about
his current weight do you think when he
when he does this stuff on Tick Tock are
you really laughing or are you concerned
about it I'm I'm concerned not so much
about his weight but more about
um his well-being
I can accept that kind of comment from
strangers
you love the man you're not concerned
about his weight
okay Chris I'm gonna go to you is that
normal
I don't know if it's normal
you find out your your partner is likely
gonna die before they even hit 60 and
you're not concerned about their weight
I don't know if it's normal but
I know [__]
I don't know if it's normal but I'm not
saying I think it's an okay thing to be
concerned about the word of your
significant other
it's a tough decision to have it's the
discussion to have
but
I mean I had it
my girl had it with me she's like yo
what we're gonna do we gotta do this we
gotta walk we gotta do we gotta do some
changes
if I find out my partner's behavior and
they're drinking was leading to them
dying earlier of course I'd be worried
about how they're drinking what
you just sit here watching your partner
drink themselves to death and you don't
get concerned is that not I feel like
I'm living in a Twilight Zone you
imagine if this man was getting on Tick
Tock boozing it up getting wasted on
[__] live all the time laughing about
how drunk and lost he is you think
that'd be fine listen it's your
relationship at the end of the day you
handle it how you want but I don't think
I could handle my loved ones getting
disobes and I'm just over here saying
I'm not concerned I understand not
wanting to condemn I understand not
wanting to insult in shame but we have
to stop doing this weird thing where
we're just walking around this [__] like
it's not a real problem the man sitting
beside you has got to be 400 pounds and
I'm being generous
there's no way he's making it past 60 at
that way
I don't know about you guys how many
people over the age of 60 do you know
that are 400 pounds and I don't like
bringing people's kids in this because
that's your family is that fair to your
child to leave them at that age it's not
even a problem when you did
it's a problem you can't play with them
the problem when you can't listen these
before this is the problem you can't
cater them run after them run with them
chill with them play with them Crouch
Lane
you go down on the floor you can't get
up
it's before death and you know yeah no
you definitely glorify it Sienna and you
guys post videos where you're jiggling
his fat and you talk about how
attractive it is and for me
a better version of myself oh yeah but
George but George the point the point
Blair's making is a sound one you say
it's to get views we know that and
you're making money from it of course
but the question is there's no incentive
for you to actually lose any weight
because of that stage your Tick Tock
is actually George is um actually on a
weight loss journey and I fully support
that I think it's more like having a
laugh at yourself making the best of you
know what made me you know what probably
around to your side George if you now
flipped with this big audience you've
got and rather than gorging yourself
every day on pizzas and donuts
why don't you actually go on a fitness
regime and show people how to lose
weight if people actually knew what I
was thinking and what I'm doing I'm
actually going to be doing it exemic
needles privately as well before you
start so all of these things we're
paying out of our own money we're not we
don't cost anyone anything maybe you're
making out of the tick tock a lot of
money like what a lot over 100 Grand oh
yeah over 100 years so there's no
incentive to lose weight is it no but it
doesn't derive straight from that that's
from my sales wow that's with the
collaborations
Are you ashamed of it no
yeah
um
like I said I don't think I can add too
much more to this I think it's sad and
the reason why I want to touch on the
systemic thing earlier was people might
say to me but that's your responsibility
in the pandemic and incorrect it is my
responsibility but I derive my physical
fitness and my health and my well-being
from being able to engage in social
activities I bike every day maybe two
hours to go dance for three four hours
then I bike back and I have all these
activities throughout the week socially
speaking that encourage me to get fit by
just doing things naturally right so
when I'm dropping all this weight it's
not just because like I made up
conscious Choice it's also because I
have the choices and the Avenues
available to me the system came in place
during the pandemic of it necessary by
some people's accounts
we can we can we can agree to disagree
on some points not being able to do [__]
not having anything I could do that was
a system in place that basically
precluded me from having my ability to
stay fit gyms is never in my thing I do
body weight exercise at home that's fine
but my biking my going out to dance all
the time that's what made everything
shut off and then the better food choice
that came afterwards because the
physical made me want to do other things
properly and that's the way that
systemically this Society helped me have
more options to be more free if I lived
in a city that didn't allow for biking
and I could only drive I would probably
be someone who struggles so I need a
place that's very pedestrian oriented
and I can move you hear me why am I
saying this because in the same way the
system helped me now have the options to
be able to reach my fitness journey to
feel my healthiest I think that systems
can also work on a Food level where they
encourage people to have better access
to Good Foods one two also say you know
some of these unhealthy Foods we need to
wash the way they're marketed we need to
be careful how they're accessible to
kids we need to also say it may not be
okay for parents to be just stuffing
their kids with donuts every day because
even though they're the parents I think
they're killing those kids
now maybe that's an extreme talking
point and I'm willing to be walk back
from this okay
but I think societally wise I think the
way we treat Sugar is insane to me but
just I think all the time we talk about
fatness and we get viral and all this
stuff it's always about the individuals
who are complicit and that's okay but we
also need to talk about systemically I
know here in Canada they ban indoor
smoking they banned slables and
advertising for tobacco companies they
put many people put the labels on it and
you saw cigarette sales plummet you
don't have [__] clip you don't have
flavors no more yes you don't have
flavors no more in tobacco you're not
allowed and even for the Vapes the Vapes
you're not the Vapes the the tobacco the
chewing tobacco yes uh the cigars yes
you don't have flavors no more and and
they fell off a [__] cliff in terms
of sales and so our society in many ways
is better for it listen giving humans
maximum freedoms sounds like a great
idea Until you realize that not all
choices are created equal one and two
not everything that you can engage in is
just born from free choice the addictive
properties of some of these things is
crazy I remember the first time I
started weeding off refined sugars you
know what the first thing that happened
bro my memory and the way I think
changed completely there was a fog that
I didn't know I was living under for a
long time that [__] faded and I was like
holy [__] I remember things I could
think clearly I could remember what I
wrote down this morning without even
having to read it
so
what am I saying these are all things
that are not that openly discussed in my
personal experience or if they are
they're not nearly as discussed or
really as readily available in terms of
like the marketing versus versus the
marketing for how tasty these products
are how much you need to have them so
I don't know I don't want to focus too
much on these two influencers because I
think people want to just have someone
they can point the finger at rather than
understanding the bigger discussion is
like systemically there's a way in which
where the society is complicit in making
people addicted to these kinds of
substances and I think if we did the
same thing for a lot of other drugs you
would see people hooked on them to Crazy
degrees but we've banned these drugs
because we said that's too far I'm
thinking we need to probably have a
better conversation about sugars
you said what you said I ain't got
nothing outside no all right
well that's it for today's video
um what do you guys think do you guys
agree